[Musique]
il ne nous parle pas encore
mais sous leurs airs inoffensifs ils
apprennent de nous
les bébés
dans leur lit sur leurs chaises dans nos
bras ils nous écoutent
décodé leur rapport au langage une
équipe de psycholinguistique doit
plonger dans les secrets de ses cerveaux
complexe
ils peuvent compter sur la technologie
et l'apport d'écrans interactifs pour
décoder le processus d'apprentissage
d'un mot
et met en place des expériences
innovantes pour étudier le rapport des
bébés à la syntaxe
car derrière leur sourire et leur peau
douce ces petits êtres cachent de
redoutables machines à stocker et
analyser de l'information
comment font-ils pour nous comprendre et
apprendre le sens de nouveaux mots
faut-il les éloigner des écrans doit-on
vraiment continuer à leur sourire
plongez vous aussi dans l'incroyable
labyrinthe du langage
[Musique]